and and after i graduated high school
that's when i became a full [__]
blown
crypto klepto whatever the [__] crypto
klepto crypto whatever the [__] it is i
mean we had this warehouse that we would
just go rob three air conditioners at a
time from
we had all these different scams here we
are seniors in high school
and we're making our mothers or our
parents not mine my friends mothers
think that they all have jobs at ups
we're stealing
i have a buddy who's making millions of
dollars at a gas station holding up
pumps
you know what that is see now you can't
do it because i got i'm telling you
the computer destroyed this economy
a decent person cannot steal no more and
make a [__] living
in the old days somebody came in for
dash i don't know if you know this
oregon and new jersey are the only
[__] states that they still pump gas
in
so this [__] you come in and
you're broke and you're going i want
three dollars worth of gas right
which happens all day long these
[__] would pump the three
dollars in your thing
and not pump the gas back in so when the
next guy came and got ten dollars he
really got seven dollars worth of gas
because there was three already on the
[__] pump but it was jersey so you
wouldn't look out the window
this kid put himself through a [__]
college bought a house
with the money he was stealing hanging
pumps when it would rain
he would go down there because people
don't get out of the [__] car
this is the and to me at this time guys
it was like i wasn't even doing nothing
bad
it was like we were just hustling that's
it just another day like
we weren't beating nobody up we weren't
stabbing nobody
nothing like that i mean the only person
i ever heard was a hooker when i took a
[__] wig and lit it on fire
and i didn't hurt her i took my
aggressions on the [__] wig you
understand me so
don't get me wrong but this you know
when you're [__] up and
and you suffer a loss i'm not making
excuses for myself but sometimes
you just go off the deep end you know
you just go off
and that whole summer of 82 i robbed
everything i even robbed you know the
local pool in your hometown
i robbed a snack bar one [__] night
now i don't you know i'm a good athlete
and stuff but i could never climb a
fence
i was always bad at the fence that's why
i'm i'm quick i was never fast i was
always quick you know what i'm saying
like i was good at tag
but if you if you chase me you catch me
file the type of [__]
but i was always good at that stuff but
i could never climb a [__] fence that
was
i was always [__] up with fences
so i'm planning this thing again i just
want to i just want to leave new jersey
i mean
i was doing so many little [__] scams
and i was selling coke and stealing coke
and all i wanted to do was just make
enough money so i could start a new life
so i had this plan
i had this [__] bookmaker i had been
putting bets in with
and i go we'll rob him this guy had you
know you ever go to somebody's house and
have a
towel room or what do you call that [__]
uh sheets
they have like a sheet and it's like
shelves with towels and [__]
this guy had a closet only with cash
my singles fives tens fifty
you go over there to pay your bills he'd
open up the closet he had like nine
locks
open it up and he'd make change for you
so after like years i go we gotta rob
this [__] guy this guy
he was in west new york new jersey and
this i had this partner he was my
brother i loved the death
you know i don't have a family my mother
died and i don't have any brothers or
sisters
so a lot of the people in the
neighborhood took me in and i always
tell people that yeah god took my
parents but he gave me a different gift
he gave me the gift of having a brother
and a sister without blood that's a very
strong gift and when
you learn it it's [__] amazing so i
had all these guys that would live and
die for me they were my street brothers
and i had this one crazy [__]
his name was stinky
he had stinky [__] feet the worst you
could smell him through the sneaker
okay you know those converse canvas you
could smell him
through the sneaker and when you lifted
weights with him whenever he bench
pressed and he pressed down
the stink would come out of the two
holes and the sneakers like [__]
smoke it was like grandpa playing the
monsters out you ever see that
when he plays the org and smoke comes
out of the [__] organ
so my plan was to rob this [__]
bookie and go back to colorado
i'm like i'm gonna [__] rob this guy
and go back to colorado
me and my buddy stinky go down there all
week guys i am flat broke i must owe
like 3 000 at this time i'm flat [__]
broke
i'm going down there and i'm buying
quarter pounders with cheese not for me
but for the guard dogs that he had so i
would go the first day and give it to
him from over the fence the second day
i'd hang a leg over
and give him a quarter pounder with
cheese meanwhile i'm not [__] eating
i'm giving him the [__] food that i
should be eating
and he's on 57th street i lived on 88th
street
so i got to walk down there and burn
calories and walk back with the [__]
food when i'm giving it to this dog
and finally by the end of the week i'm
over the fence with the dog throwing a
ball for him giving him the quarter
pounder
so i call stink and i go sticky we're
ready to break into this [__] bookies
joint
now this is a cuban neighborhood stinky
love he was italian he loved cuban food
and there's this cuban restaurant on the
corner and when he pulls up i go sticky
listen for me you know pay attention
and right away he says to me i'm kind of
hungry i go stinky i don't give a [__]
if you're hungry
don't get out of the [__] car watch
that roof because i'm gonna be on the
roof i'm gonna burger i'm gonna go
through the back jump the fence
there's a dog i'm gonna jump another
[__] fence and then i'm gonna get
into the bookmaker's house don't [__]
move
so i go back there i got a screwdriver i
got my little mask with the eyes in it
i go back there i climb the [__]
thing i get on the roof
i get the screwdriver i'm [__] now
there's
there's the window this is where the
roof is ends
there's an alleyway and there's a fence
i hear
bring a one-nine or whatever like a
walkie-talkie and i see a flashlight and
i'm like this with the thing and i look
down
and i see these cops walking over here
they don't see me on this ledge i'm like
oh god
they're gonna get me the dog is barking
but he's my buddy
i've been giving him [__] hamburgers
all week this [__]
all i gotta do is get to that fence and
i'm good to go
so i wait to these cops take like 10
more steps and i go all the way to the
[__] wall
and i just jump and i go over the next
fence and i land and they turn around
and the dog is like oh and i'm like it's
me i forgot what his name was like
casper i'm like casp it's your uncle
joey he's like i don't give a [__] [__]
the stakes are high you know what i'm
saying the cops are here they're
watching me he was like a german
shepherd
he's trying to bite me i'm you [__]
sucker all week i've been getting
where's the loyalty
i thought you were man's best friend you
[__] traitor
so he's biting my leg i'm trying to
punch him in the head he's biting i'm
like you [__]
and i start [__] running i'm just
running running running
and the cops like come back here hall
police and all this [__] there's an amp
a supermarket
and right there there's a fence with
barbed wire on top and i'm like i can't
make this fan so i'm just gonna
[__] high halt this [__] like
an olympic guy
whatever you call it what's that [__]
when you jump over the [__] things
and your
hurdles hurdles i'm gonna high hurdle
this [__]
meanwhile it's a seven foot [__]
fence right
so i'm like i'm going for broke and i'm
picking up speed and i'm looking at this
and i'm hearing freeze freeze freeze and
i [__] hit the fence and i put my leg
over and i'm over
i'm [__] over i put the leg over i'm
over
i put the other [__] leg over i'm
over and as i let go the [__] barbed
wire
goes into my hand presses and there i am
hanging from the [__]
barbed wire the bloods hit me in the
face i don't know if you guys know i
can't see blood i start fainting right
so by this time i'm pale i'm hanging in
i'm crying like a [__]
and i'm thinking when i got out of jail
in 20 years i'm gonna come back and stab
this [__] dog
because all week he took me he's a
[__] traitor the [__]
and they're coming close to me close to
me i [__] pulled up a little bit i'm
fainting by this point
and i had a glove on and the glove had
tangled with the [__] skin
and i closed my hand with no money and
started [__] running
so i had to run from 57 back to 88th
street
and as i'm walking into my house a cop
car makes a turn
and i dropped to the floor because they
knew somebody was running they were
going through all the side streets they
[__] knew it
but i got away with it and i didn't get
caught but that was one of my wake-up
calls i'm like jesus
[__] christ look what the [__] i'm
doing